summer 2017 was chock-full of great
films from blockbuster superhero sagas
to streaming only surprises franchises
were revived with bigger franchises were
brilliantly wrapped up legacies were
secured and Charlize Theron's probably
had more fun than anyone in the business
these are the best of the best from a
season full of fantastic films Wonder
Woman
after 75 odd years of whooping bad guy
but in the comic pages Wonder Woman
finally got her shot at solo blockbuster
glory just in time to either make or
break the emerging DC extended universe
Wonder Woman did everything it needed to
and then some serving as an effective
origin story as well as a superhero
adventure that stood on its own as a
standalone experience while continuing
to lay the groundwork for the DCE use
big team-up in Justice League the
reviews have been almost universally
positive and audiences have turned out
in droves laying the groundwork for a
real battle for superhero supremacy at
the box office between Marvel and DC
atomic blonde this neon thriller takes
place in the final days of the Cold War
the Berlin Wall is about to go down but
that doesn't mean the cloak-and-dagger
business is over to the contrary a super
spy played by Charlize Theron is sent to
Germany to retrieve a stolen list that
contains the names of undercover spies
the list has fallen into the hands of
the Soviets and Charlize will have to
bash a few skulls in request to discover
that document but honestly the plot
isn't that important the insane fight
choreography is the star here Charlize
beats up dudes using everything from
shoes to ropes to cooking pots all while
wearing the most stylish clothes
imaginable the actress did her own
stunts for atomic blonde adding a touch
of realism to the brutal battle scenes
and car chases
[Music]
okhta Netflix's okiya is a film that
starts off feeling like a g-rated kid's
adventure and ends up inside a very
r-rated slaughterhouse the film tells
the story of a young girl who's friends
with a hippo like super pig named okhta
that actually belongs to the
all-powerful mirando corporation a
business run by evil twins both played
by Tilda Swinton obviously okiya is
their genetically modified creation and
they plan on turning the poor pig into
the tastiest most eco-friendly pork
chops on the planet but not if the girl
in the team of animal activists rescue
okhta first a darkly comic vision of the
future okhta has quite a lot to say
about the evils of capitalism and the
merits of a plant-based diet while also
offering up a wildly entertaining and
inventive piece of filmmaking war for
the Planet of the Apes the conclusion to
one of the best film trilogies ever war
for the Planet of the Apes expertly
blends the book of Exodus with
Apocalypse Now resulting in a brutal Old
Testament pows story in the fiery
aftermath of the previous film Caesar
has led his followers into the mountains
hoping to escape the wrath of man but
Caesar knows his apes can't hide in the
hills for long so this primate Moses
plans on leading his people to a new
promised land where they can avoid any
future conflicts this sets up a bridge
on the river kwai style showdown between
Caesar and a mad colonel played by Woody
Harrelson war for the Planet of the Apes
is the perfect ending of the trilogy
featuring a show-stopping oscar-worthy
motion capture performance from Andy
Serkis spider-man homecoming one of the
most charming and entertaining films to
ever swing its way into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
spider-man homecoming follows wannabe
Avenger Peter Parker as he tries to
fight crime and navigate high school at
the same time things get even more
complicated when an honest-to-goodness
supervillain shows up Michael Keaton's
vulture is the ultimate thief and a
feeder can bring him to justice it could
be his ticket into the Avengers one of
the best comic book movies ever made
homecoming even one over Marvel haters
thanks to its John Hughes like high
school vibe and all that upbeat energy
was largely thanks to Tom Holland who's
a pitch-perfect Peter Parker dunkirk
without a doubt the epic World War two
thriller Dunkirk is one of Christopher
Nolan's
latest achievements right up there with
inception in the dark night shot mostly
with 65 millimeter film on IMAX cameras
the nail-biting Dunkirk tells the story
of a real-life military retreat in 1940
roughly 400,000 Allied troops were
trapped on a French beach completely
surrounded and the only thing keeping
them from home was the English Channel
unfortunately the beach was too shallow
to accommodate military sized vessels so
English civilians sprang into action
sailing to Dunkirk in their yachts and
fishing boats
Nolan masterfully uses three
interlocking tails to put audiences
right in the middle of the battlefield
baby driver with its eclectic soundtrack
and insanely impressive driving stunts
Edgar Wright's baby driver is one of the
most exciting films of 2017 this
souped-up action flick starts ansel
elgort is baby a young man who works as
a getaway driver for a smarmy crime boss
played by Kevin Spacey suffering from
tinnitus baby drowns out the constant
droning with an incredible collection of
tunes to soundtrack his incredible
driving skills baby wants to go straight
but he gets pulled into a robbery gone
wrong so he's forced to take a stand to
save everything he loves with its dance
like action and it's super cool
characters write 6 feature film is like
a mash-up between singing in the rain
and Walter Hills the driver which means
it's got a little something for everyone
I want us to head west I never stop
anyway I mean baby thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love too
you